6 24 on your friday morning you know the
stories we do about the 95 the northern
215 beltway well it's not always about
the freeways come on along let's go
centennial bowling
so the reason the freeways are even
there is the explosive growth in the
area and for folks who have moved their
lives there it's also about keeping your
neighborhood streets safe
at the intersection of grand teton and
grand canyon that means goodbye stop
sign
and hello traffic signals to help
drivers get used to the signals they'll
stay on all way red flashing lights till
monday morning engineers from the city
of las vegas on hand yesterday morning
making sure everything was good to go
from taking the covers off all the fresh
signs to the innards of the signal
control box
all right in addition to three
previously activated signals osoblanca
farm road oso blanca grand montecito
grand teton at hualapai sky village
three more intersections are getting new
signals in the coming weeks here we're
talking about centennial parkway at fort
apache deer springs and grand canyon
farm road in grand canyon now there's
not going to be a quiz and you can
review all of this in the online version
of this along with all our centennial
bowling stories on the website
8newsnow.com click traffic then driving
me crazy buckle up drive carefully
please put down that phone now if
there's something driving you crazy
email me traffic 8 8newsnow.com